this is the man family from Cornwall and
these are their provisions food and
drink for several months for five people
plus their cat and dog just in case
there's the worst case we're not
preparing for war or famine we're
preparing for exit the man's have always
been against Britain leaving the EU and
everything they've heard from London in
the last two years makes them think
brexit is going to be a chaotic process
they've bought a water tank with a
filter and because the UK gets some of
its electricity from Europe they're
getting ready for power cuts so we're
being a bit balanced and realistic we're
not expecting there to be unexpected
power cuts frequent leave more rationing
of power much like the 70s where they
were set times of the day where they
wouldn't be power the whole family helps
out with the weeding they hope that
their homegrown greens will soon be
ready to eat is all this a bit too much
maybe but midwife Naveen says they're
simply going on what they've heard from
their government the UK government has
then said they expect up to six months
of in imports running on 15 to 20%
efficiency I think so we're now
increasing because we had underestimated
what we might need the Mann family say
they only rely on themselves others
haven't given up the fight yet it's
early morning in London and a group of
young people are about to get on a
campaign bus their organisation is
called our future our choice just like
59% of the British population they want
a second referendum there's a lot to do
and we're gonna look back on this moment
for years to come and ask ourselves
whether we did enough but I think that
the ties really are turning there's a
real opportunity for us now
Catherine really make a case according
to polls some seventy-seven percent of
Britons under the age of 24 would vote
against leaving the EU and every day
more young people are becoming old
enough to vote the message that these
activists are promoting please stand up
for our future
the man family in Cornwall have long
since given up hoping Britain will
remain in the EU they don't think it's
going to end well either so they're
heading back to the shops to stock up on
more food
you